[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
où nous allons aborder essentiellement
deux grands sujets de l'actualité
évidemment cet acte d'une sauvagerie
inouïe de barbarie dont a été victime un
professeur d'histoire à conflans sainte
honorine
vendredi dernier nous allons essayer de
d'en étudier dans regarder quelles
pourraient être les conséquences on a
l'impression qu'il me prise de
conscience du danger de l'islamisme
radical
et puis on parlera aussi de la situation
de la co vite dans laquelle nous mais là
que vit depuis ce que veut dire la co
vide avec cette situation du couvre-feu
alors en plateau pour en parler
alexandrine vigueur bonjour vous êtes je
vous ai demandé de venir parce que vous
êtes étudiante et j'aimerais bien voir
le regard d'une jeune femme sur cette
situation
et puis notre invité bertrand guillon
bonjour bonjour vous êtes le maire de
magny les hameaux
vous appartenez au mouvement génération
qui avait été fondée par benoît hamon et
puis avec nous à merveille bezina
duclair bonjour jean patrice alors vous
êtes toujours maître de conférences à
l'université de rouen c'est ce qui est
intéressant c'est que nous avons avec
nous des enseignants a donc vous
interviennent
vous en batiste du clae vous êtes vous
êtes maître de conférences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
vincent couronne vous avez enseigné à la
science ou notamment à sciences po saint
germain et vous est aussi le fondateur
des surligneurs et vous nous donnerez ou
de vrais faux justement sur ce qui se
dit actuellement notamment sur les
fichiers s
et c'est sur les expulsions possible et
puis jean charles lajoie ni vous êtes
éditeur mais vous êtes aussi enseignant
à rambouillet un absolument lutter
l'embrouillé à l'iut de renvoyer donc
c'est important parce que ce sont au
fond et c'est assez de nouveau c'est la
première fois il ya eu des policiers qui
ont été touchés ces pâles récemment des
journalistes et l'ascension c'est un
enseignant qui a été donc décapité très
sauvagement agressé par ce jeune
chrétienne au fond du ltte coincés par
vous bertrand guillot qu'est ce que ça
nous dit l'agression d'un enseignant
d'abord je veux vraiment apporter mon
soutien à ces
à ses proches ses élèves aussi à ses
collègues et finalement à l'ensemble des
enseignants de france qui qui sont là
tout simplement pour faire leur métier
et aujourd'hui cet assassinat sauvage
nous montre que en faisant simplement
son métier et dans la continuité des
policières et policiers en faisant
simplement son métier en france dans le
cadre républicain
on peut payer de sa vie c'est tout
simplement atroce et ça pose un certain
nombre de questions sur la réalité de
notre république et de de l'acceptation
aussi de notre république cdr de nos de
nos fondamentaux de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité mais aussi de notre loi
républicaine par un certain nombre de
nos concitoyens
alexandrine vous êtes étudiant vous avez
beaucoup utilisent plutôt dans les pays
anglo saxons mais est-ce que vous êtes
arrivé parfois d'être choqué par ce que
vous pouvez dire un enseignant dans le
cadre où j'ai fait mes études c'était
toujours très contrôlés et très on
savait que le contexte était fait pour
les cours il n'avait pas de moments
choquant parce qu'on s'attendait tous à
un contexte pareil donc non pas
forcément
non pas forcément d'accord et mêmes
enfin on peut admettre évidemment c'est
un des problèmes que pose que pose cette
affaire c'est à dire qu'est ce que c'est
la laïcité
qu'est ce que c'est la liberté
d'expression c'est ça qui vous démontrez
d'ordre dans ce cours est évidemment on
va y revenir mais il ya eu une campagne
qui a été menée par un certain nombre de
parents d'élèves attendent activists and
charlene
justement le en tant qu'enseignante
comment vous comment vous réagissez à ce
cet acte barbare
je réagis en temps 80 d'abord c'est à
dire la cruauté que l'on ressent et
finalement la même peine que l'on a eues
en 2015 avec les attentats de charlie de
nice c'est cette atteinte à la vie de
toute façon qui est qui et qui nous fait
du mal ensuite c'est vrai que ça pose
des questions en tant qu'enseignante je
trouve qu'on on jouit d'une véritable
liberté de parole qui est quand même le
fondement de notre république et qu'on
espère évidemment ne pas perdre ensuite
vivre ensemble c'est quelque chose qui
en effet nécessite parfois des siècles
pour pour rendre quelque chose
d'harmonieux on a le sentiment
aujourd'hui qu'entre l'aco vide les le
risque de séparatisme on a le sentiment
qu'on n'a jamais eu autant de mal à être
une communauté unique et je crois que
c'est vraiment ça qui fait souffrir
entendre c'est cette idée de se dire
qu'on peut pas vivre forcément de
manière apaisée tous ensemble moi je je
crois qu'il faut tendre vers cet idéal
et que l'essentiel des mesures ou des
réactions qu'il faut que nous ayons sont
soit celle ci c'est à dire des mesures
de cohésion nationale vinça où jean
baptiste est gérable est-ce qu'il faut
protéger les profs et comment moi je
pense qu'il n'y a pas à protéger les
profs
il ya pour beaucoup d'hommes politiques
à bien se remettre en cause parce que
beaucoup d'hommes politiques et beaucoup
de partis politiques sont responsables
de ce qui est arrivé avec cette
complaisance qui a eu pendant des années
des années des années sur soutenir sa
famille a lancé oui non mais c'est très
important et donc il ya pas besoin de
protéger alors c'est très bien on va
mettre le 3 novembre des policiers
devant chaque école
mais le risque n'est pas là c'est ce
qu'il faut c'est que effectivement on
puisse parler de tout et sans que des
partis politiques ou là là attention ne
stigmatisait pas ne faites pas ça nord
on a peur et c'est donc ça j'espère que
maintenant tous ces partis politiques
vont faire un peu une sorte
d'autocritique et on va arrêter un peu
avec ça il n'y a pas besoin de
protection en tant que tel
de liberté et de la liberté de
s'exprimer pour un prof mais pour tout
le monde pour un journaliste de ne pas
participer de chape de plomb sur les
mêmes dans les émissions de télévision
dans les émissions de radio ou naissants
arrête dès qu'on parle d'une religion à
niamey mais attention je parle aussi des
deux autres parce que surtout vous pas
se focaliser sur une seule
il faut arrêter avec ça il faut appeler
un chat un chat c'est indispensable
j'aurais juste dire une chose c'est que
j'étais absolument bluffé et je sais que
j'ai souvent la dent dure notamment sur
quelques chroniqueur de france inter
mais que sophia aram qui est d'habitude
d'une lourdeur incroyable a fait ce
matin à papier absolument remarquable en
tous points et elle suivait un autre un
autre intervenant qui était bernard
cazeneuve qui a été vraiment grandiose
ce matin donc très intéressant
politiquement est vraiment est quelqu'un
de très intéressant jean baptiste et
vincent oui c'est heureux sur quand même
est-ce qu'il ya des professeurs qui
peuvent avoir peur après ce qui s'est
produit quand même confiance à tony ça
pourrait se comprendre
bajeux givet où tu joues baptisé dans
les allées je pense qu'effectivement il
ya des enseignants qui doivent avoir
plus peur maintenant de faire des cours
sur liberté d'expression qu'auparavant
en revanche il ça ne nécessite pas selon
moi plus un renforcement sécuritaire aux
policiers notamment aux abords des
écoles parce que ça ne réglerait pas le
problème je crois même d'ailleurs que
samuel patty a été attaqué à une
certaine distance de son établissement
or l' annonce hier de deck de l'exécutif
de renforcer la sécurité des
établissements scolaires nous sommes de
ceux du coup n'aurait pas eu d'effet là
dans ce cas de figure
en réalité il faut réussir à faire c'est
n'ont pas renforcé les contrôles
policiers
mais c'est tout simplement renforcer la
cohésion nationale
plus dit moi je pense que c est à la
racine en fait qu'il faut s'attaquer et
non pas aux symptômes ou ces
manifestations sauvages est épuisé notre
question à vous poser
effectivement on après je crois que ceux
qui ne lisent pas une personne n'égalera
sa qualité en saignant policiers
discours en disant que la république est
attaquée c'est vrai que ni la qualité de
la personne
je crois qu'en fait c'est toute personne
qui est tout simplement un discours qui
va au bourg de l'individu pensez donc
aujourd'hui un enseignant peut être
demain le plancher donc c'est s'il
fallait prendre des mesures soient
spécifiques à chaque à chaque corps se
serait finalement chaque geste et chaque
français qu'il faut donc il n'y a pas à
ça cela de mesure particulière à prendre
sinon toujours augmenter tant que cela
est possible les moyens de la police
administrative préventive puisque
l'individu on se fait donner lui-même la
mort c'est en amont qu'il faut pouvoir
intervenir et c'est de ce côté là qu'il
faut renforcer mon corps quand je dis
protéger ses dires il ya en réalité deux
de deux choses il ya en effet ce
terrorisme ce nouveau terrorisme auquel
on a essayé depuis quelques années
qu'ils sont qui est fait d'actes isolés
c'est à dire si d'individus dont on ne
connaissait pas grand chose avant le
tchétchène en question n'étaient pas
fichés s par exemple il n'avait pas eu
de véritable manifestation et qui
pouvaient inquiéter alors il ya en effet
ces actes isolés qui sont très
difficiles à prévenir mais il ya aussi
tout ce qui excite ces gens notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux
et on l'a vu dans la sphère de conflent
et eu un parent d'élève il ya eu un un
islamiste qui qui qui était très présent
sur les réseaux sociaux qui ont excité
au fond et qui ont appelé à ces actes de
barbarie
est-ce que c'est pas là aussi qu'il
faudrait peut-être agir sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment quatre ans c'est à mon
avis d'abord sur la cohésion nationale
de remettre
au coeur des choses les communs que nous
avons l'éducation fait partie de
revaloriser le métier d'enseignant et et
de le défendre coûte que coûte de
défendre aussi mais on le verra tout à
l'heure sur sur la copie de la santé il
faut absolument que la république soit
au coeur de l'ensemble de la vie
quotidienne les des français les réseaux
sociaux on peut toujours et surtout on
peut toujours essayer de limiter
l'ensemble des libertés en france je
pense que ce n'est pas comme ça qu'on
réussira protéger notre liberté dont il
est question en ce moment de remettre en
place ou demander à ce que les
algorithmes serait plus humanisé de
toute façon par rapport à l'imed
l'immédiateté des réseaux sociaux on
aura toujours du retard
par contre qu'il y ait par l'éducation
par une refondation de notre vivre
ensemble
alors c'est complexe pour une fois qu'on
a dit ça mais par ce biais là on aura
aussi une vraie régulation une vraie
défense du mode de vie que nous avons de
cette liberté de travail pour l'égalité
aussi de de fraternité finalement dire
tout le monde et c'est pas uniquement
sur sur des problèmes de laïcité il ya
il ya d'autres exemples où des
enseignants se retrouvent pris à partie
par des par des parents sur des
enseignements qu'il donne et qui sont
des enseignements classiques
je pense par exemple à l'homosexualité
dès la maternelle à la l'apprentissage
de la sexualité etc sur un certain
nombre d'éléments régulièrement nos
enseignants sont pris à partie par les
parents qui doivent les laisser
enseigner librement dans le cadre de la
loi
il ya eu des affaires enfin réseau tbc
en scène sur l'enseignement de la shoah
notamment sur voltaire même parce que
voltaire critiquer les révisions sur
madame bovary parce que c'était une
femme fidèle ya pas mal de
nature est ce que au fond par le juriste
est-ce qu'on pourrait finalement
interdire d'école je ne sais pas vous
prendre des mesures contre ceux qui ne
veulent pas que cet enseignement qui
l'enseignement républicains soient
prodigués
je crois que le premier problème qu'on
va rencontrer c'est un problème
d'identification et c'est celui que l'on
rencontre avec le phénomène de la
déradicalisation il ne faut pas du tout
imaginé qu'on est dans un système
démunis la france a une législation qui
est très solidement établie depuis 2015
sur le phénomène terroriste et la
déradicalisation le seul problème c'est
la mise en oeuvre c'est à dire qu'il est
difficile dans une république
d'identifier ceux qui n'ont pas la même
idéologie et je crois que ce qu'on
oublie très souvent de dire dans ce type
d'acte tellement tellement violent qui
nous qui nous atteignent tous au niveau
de la passion du sentiment ce qu'on
oublie de dire c'est que nous sommes en
train de lutter contre une idéologie
donc ça met du temps et ça suppose
surtout d'utiliser des moyens qui ne
sont pas uniquement des moyens
législatifs et qui ne sont pas
uniquement des moyens d'interdiction il
faut d'abord identifier qui ne se sent
pas concerné par les valeurs de la
république donc ici exclure un élève
évidemment c'est possible pour des
motifs disciplinaires interdire une
activité c'est possible également
sanctionner les réseaux sociaux moi je
crois alors je rejoins partiellement ce
qui a été dit parce qu en effet je pense
qu'il faut d'abord travailler sur la
cohésion avant de travailler sur des
mesures sectorielles
néanmoins il faut peut-être pas oublier
quand même que il ya un rôle des
modérateurs de ce type de réseau qui est
assez diminué et que dans d'autres états
on rencontre quand même avec plus de
force alors il ya toujours cette
frontière de la liberté d'expression les
réseaux se sont évidemment des lieux de
liberté d'expression mais on a quand
même une législation sur la presse sur
la diffamation sur les atteintes à
l'honneur sur l'atteinte au vivre
ensemble justement puisqu'on ne peut pas
avoir deux discours incitant à la haine
eh bien je crois que les modérateurs des
réseaux sociaux pourrait jouer un rôle
on a déjà parlé ensemble de la ferme il
où on se rend compte de la même chose il
y a un problème des médias tu es en
effet mais peut-être aussi que nous nous
mobilisons pas suffisamment de deux
personnels de problèmes de vérité autour
de ce problème de l'identification il
faudrait arriver à agir en amont et pas
uniquement en aval mais alors pour
parler concrètement par exemple
revenons à cette affaire de 2,2 de
l'assassinât de samuel pâtit ce ce
parent d'élève et sept activistes
islamistes qui ont qui sont prononcés
sur les réseaux sociaux
l'un portait plainte d'ailleurs contre
le professeur est ce qu'ils sont pas où
vous allez dire aussi coupables que le
que que l'assassin lui-même est ce
qu'ils sont en tout cas deux complices
nous battre complices de cet acte
bien sûr ils sont quasiment instigateurs
de cet acte parce que des bras armés on
en trouvera toujours des crétins mais ce
sens va en avoir à foison mais
effectivement les gens qui les poussent
à ce genre de crime qui les incite qui
les excite etc
c'est ça le vrai danger et on a un petit
peu l'impression qu'en france il ya eu
comme une sorte de deux permis à points
du radicalisme ou de l'islam et dire sur
l'histoire pardon qui s'est instaurée
parce que là alors il faut qu'on
décapite un prof d'histoire-géo pour que
tout d'un coup on se dit ah bah tiens on
à 281,6 chez est-ce qu'on pourrait
expulser maintien bat maintenant
savourer les expulser ah bah tiens on a
des imams qui continue à prêcher de des
trucs scandaleux ah bah tiens on les
connaît on va on va intervenir et tout
d'un coup on est absent on se réveille
ce matin d alors qu'est-ce que faudrait
ces gens est ce qu'ils sont ils sont pas
tenues plus dangereux depuis avant-hier
non hélas tout net morelli toi là bas
ils ont dépassé la limite alors on leur
retire tous leurs points on leur retire
la famille on va enfin les mettre dehors
mais qu'est ce qu'on attendait qu'est ce
que c'est que qu'est ce que c'est que
cette façon de désirs et les choses tout
d'un coup on dit ah ben on a on a tous
les coupables on a tous les gens qui
sont hors la loi bah oui mais finalement
on va se réveiller
ah non alors je sais bien que c'est très
difficile d'expulser mais ça va prendre
avant tout à l'heure charles sur la
question justement avec vincent couronne
sur la question juridique de l'expulsion
déficiences et vous verrez que c'est pas
et c'est en effet
vraiment facile n'est pas vraiment
possible d'ailleurs mais bah oui mais on
a un droit qu'il faut aussi respecter et
la magie c'est aussi c'est aussi
l'honneur des démocraties parfois de
respecter ce droit la caf se redire
devrait lundi
alors ces annonces aujourd'hui et voilà
donc il ya une incohérence totale alors
jean baptiste par exemple sur sur ces
gens qui ont incité peut-être à l'acte
peut-être peut-être pas volontairement
je ne sais pas mais est-ce que ils
peuvent être poursuivies est ce qu ils
peuvent être condamnés à l'oratoire est
créé pour inciter inciter à quoi dans
dans l'est en tout cas les propos qui
ont été tenus par une personne qui en
parle
auteurs de l'acte je crois pas que
l'incitation au crime
c'est plutôt un discours qui a été
portée et qui aussi d'ailleurs
condamnable sur sur des lits propos qui
ont été tenus par cet enseignant qui est
à liberté d'expression que l'écart entre
le cds est en soi disant au contraire
aux valeurs de la république mais sur le
plan purement pénale il faut faire
attention puisque s'il n'ya pas
d'incitation à la haine d'incitation au
critt au crime
on n'est pas dans les cas d'infractions
pénales qui sont similaires à celles
attribuées aux commanditaires à celui
qui a exercé l action il n'ya pas alors
il ya parfois un montage et utile qui
est fait en droit pénal avec l'exécutant
est le commanditaire la danse monde
entend nul donc sont ses dents il n'y a
pas une demande de tuer cet enseignant
donc il faut pas mettre sur le même plan
ce genre de propos et le passage à
l'acte a fait d'ailleurs nous mêmes à
voir aux critiques exprimées sont sont
peu d'attrait pour produire la liste si
derrière quelqu'un a tenté physiquement
à cette personne ça ne rend pas jean
charles responsable de finale
c'est peut-être une piste juridique
peut-être saisir puisque le président de
la république l'a dit ils ne savent pas
ils ne passeront pas les islamistes ne
doivent plus pouvoir dormir tranquille
il y eut des phrases très forte du
président de république est là dessus
vous voulez interdir alexandrie après
oui éventuellement et puisque ce que je
pense qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
c'est que cette affaire rappelle que ce
qui se passe sur les réseaux sociaux ça
n'est pas quelque chose de virtuel ça
les réseaux sociaux numériques ce n'est
pas un monde virtuel c'est qu'on a
l'impression que à force de parler d'
univers numérique
on est dans une sorte d'immense jeu
vidéo dans lequel des choses en fait
tout est permis ou rien et réprimer ce
sera à la justice de dire si oui ou non
les parents les proches etc ont commis
des fautes pénales mais que ça soit dans
la dont la vie dans la rue de tous les
jours et c'est nous mêmes dans le monde
virtuel
tout est bien réelle et les thèmes des
mêmes infractions pénales s'applique que
ce soit effectivement l'incitation à la
haine
l'incitation au meurtre ou même la
dénonciation calomnieuse ces choses là
sont absolument réels dans la vie
numérique
quand moi j'écris quelque chose sur sur
twitter et que j'appuie suis rentré pour
l'envoyer c'est bien boutons physiques
qui envoie une impulsion électrique sur
notre ordinateur qui va lui faire
apparaître un message on n'est pas du
tout dans quelque chose d'irréel
mais bien dans la vie réelle il faut là
aussi c'est une question de moyens et on
y revient toujours
il pas besoin de renforcer notre arsenal
répressif pour lutter contre ça ici fut
il suffit simplement d'avoir une
administration qui applique pleinement
le droit et qui a les moyens de le faire
et c'est sans doute une des pistes qui
va être observée par notamment le
ministre de l'intérieur alors je reviens
peut-être ce que disait il on charles
tout à l'heure c'est à dire l histoire
et c'est intéressant
au fond si on regarde un petit peu le le
la sphère du voile de creil c'était en
1989 c'est à dire il ya un peu plus 30
ans et beaucoup de gens jean pierre
chevènement par exemple dans son livre
dix ans on a perdu du temps c'est à ce
moment là qu'il aurait fallu agir azir
for as a service était plus simple de le
faire on ne l'a pas fait et et j'ai je
me tourne vers vous pas personnellement
mais c'est vrai que par exemple vous
êtes puisque vous êtes du mouvement
générations beaucoup pensent à manuel
valls ont reproché à benoît hamon par
exemple d'avoir je sais que benoît mans
il ya des ambiguïtés des risques
d'accommodement avec l'hymne d'islamisme
radical de la part de benoît hamon des
t-bonds je veux pas vous le défendre
mais est ce que la gauche a pas une part
de responsabilité c'est à dire que c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas voulu dénommé nommé
même le l'islamisme radical par peur de
stigmatiser les musulmans il ya eu cette
phrase qu'on entend et quand on entend
par exemple
mélenchon qui était qui était hier dans
la rue dire parler au fond dedans dans
cette affaire du problème de shenzhen 1
c'est ça qu'il a mis en avant sa pause
quand même ça pose quand même des
problèmes est ce que est ce que la
gauche a peut-être à refaire son examen
de conscience sur cette affaire où
est-ce que vous pensez que n'ont cessé
je pense surtout qu'on a un vrai
problème avec la mise en application de
la laïcité en france de manière générale
est qui et qui bute sur un certain
nombre de
de la tradition d'un côté et deux hommes
et d'histoire n'ont accepté non digérée
en fait de la france de manière générale
et aux sites sont que de son
colonialisme en fait on a plein de
choses qui guide sur la laïcité sur la
licité un moment sa vie et sur sur nos
communes par exemple on a la
responsabilité d'une mise en application
de cette laïcité sur la commune de magny
les hameaux
aucune aucune religion n'a accès à des
bâtiments publics
aucune mais quelle qu'elle soit et ses
vues avec l'ensemble des responsables
religieux et puis il ne faut pas oublier
aussi que dans la laïcité
il y à cette liberté de penser de
croyance de croire ou de ne pas croire
aussi
et là dessus il est essentiel que même à
l'échelle de nos collectivités nous
n'entrions pas danser fonctionnement est
régulièrement j'ai eu des des
responsables religieux qui m'ont demandé
pour pouvoir accéder à des bâtiments
publics pour pouvoir mettre en place un
certain nombre d'animations
je les ai toujours refusé on l'a
toujours expliqué on s'est toujours
expliqué ensemble là dessus il y a et
quelles que soient les religions de la
part de l'état ou de collectivités donc
de responsables politiques des façons de
réagir très différentes
et aujourd'hui il faut que nous
revenions à ses fondamentaux la loi
existe et elle doit être mise en
application directement et vous avez
raison de rappeler aux faux que la
laïcité c'est la sphère de tous que ça
commence en effet dans les communes
mexès commence aussi même dans les
comportements personnels titre a bien
entendu c'est l'autre même s'il a une
religion différente ou même s'il n'en a
pas internet
je reviens cette question historique est
ce que vous avez vous comme dit par
exemple chevènement mais comme le dit
jean
j'ai l'impression qu'on a perdu du temps
là là c'est vrai que dans son discours
des mureaux emmanuel macron a nommé
spécifiquement l'islamisme radical
mais ça faisait 20 ans qui avait une
sorte de silence assourdissant des chefs
d'état ou des premiers ministres là
dessus nommé c'est une chose agir sans
honte encore une autre et je ne suis pas
sûr que le mouvement que cette affaire a
conduit à opérer qui est aujourd'hui une
sorte de 2,2 bougeotte législatives on a
le sentiment que gérald darmanin va
bouillonner de nouvelles mesures pénales
et ces suppressions ce soit ça la
réponse qui soit la première qui
viennent à l'esprit et je ne sais pas si
on peut parler de retard ou d'inertie ou
de phénomènes de droite ou de gauche sur
ces questions parce que on a un
phénomène religieux qui s'est répandue
et qui sait aussi accommodé de
différents mouvements à l'intérieur même
du goût et l'islamisme radical n'avait
pas la force qu'il a aujourd'hui
en 1989 et parler du voile de craig
c'était aussi posé la question du
cosmopolitisme de la manière dont on
allait pouvoir vivre ensemble et je ne
suis pas certaine que ce soit cela même
qui est à l'origine de ce que nous
vivons comme radicalisme et comme
terrorisme sur nos territoires
aujourd'hui la france l'allemagne les
états unis la nouvelle zélande nous
monde entier a été confronté à ce
phénomène par rapport à des groupuscules
on a pu penser à al qaïda l'état
islamique etc qui se sont constitués
alors sur le colonialisme sûr on l'a dit
voilà sur sur un sur un agrégat de
phénomènes historiques qui ont conduit à
la situation nous vivons aujourd'hui
dans moi je suis patient soit un retard
législatif ou politiques que nous que
nous constatons en france mais
simplement l'évolution d'un phénomène
idéologique sur lequel aucun
gouvernement du monde n'a de prise donc
on est tous in in or en face à cela et
sur la manière d'agir donc il faut
solutionner le problème à la source est
arrivé à trouver
les moyens d'identifier ces mouvements
est d'arriver à faire le nécessaire en
suisse mais je crois vraiment le
problème est un problème d' évolution
exponentielle et incontrôlée de ce type
de mouvements jeu pas sur ce son amour à
manque de courage politique
je crois que par liam charlène de nommer
les choses et c'est très bien de les
nommer et beaucoup de personnel
politique n'ose pas le nommer les choses
et par exemple je ne crois pas avoir
entendu monsieur le maire va se bat
depuis ce matin prononcé le seul mot de
islamisme vous n'avez pas arrêté
monsieur de nous dire que toutes les
religions vous interdisez toutes les
religions que cette et globale que
machin on parle de quoi aujourd'hui on
parle de l'islam ils n'ont pas dire les
choses il faut oser en parler il faut
vous n'avez pas cessé de nous dire mais
oui mais toutes les religions sont
concernés non toutes les religions ne
sont pas concernés par la blesser
capitation de deux adultes ali cité la
visite à asmara la laïcité positive
n'est pas de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et de la laïcité
voilà c'est pas la peine de se alors si
tu ne pas oser prononcer les mots c'est
une première chose et deuxième rangs
prononcer un deuil de la laissera encore
une fois personne ne parle du bouquin
remarque est sorti le bouquin de
l'inspecteur général de l'éducation la
aubin qui vient de sortir et qui
s'appelle comment on a laissé
d'islamisme pénétrer l'école c'est comme
un homme un bouquin majeur et s'est il
encore une fois on en a un petit peu
parlé sur france inter mais ça a l'air
vraiment d'être on touche à un brûlot
quoi donc
parlons-en parlons-en ce type a écrit ce
livre après quatre ans banquette
comment l'islam is a pénétré l'école
commandes à l'essai par manque
l'islamisme payer l'école il faut dire
les choses il faut les nommer nommer les
choses c'est déjà la pallice
mission sur le séparatisme concordat
fait il ya quinze jours et dans lequel
il y avait des gens qui a talonné dans
des quartiers difficiles et qui qui
étaient très pessimistes dans leurs
discours qu'ils aient même on en a on
est trop porta on a déjà perdu la
bataille mais je ne veux pas défense
versailles où veut il parler de la
laïcité du rôle du maire par rapport à
la laïcité est évidemment qu'on vous
parle vous êtes mère et vous pourrez de
laïcité vous n'allez pas interdire et de
reddition à une autre voilà c'était non
mais je j'ai interpelle sur le fait qu'
on peut trouver parfois des des
différences de traitement suivant les
religions directement sur le terrain et
c'est là la grande difficulté que nous
pouvons avoir dans la mise en
application sur le terrain de notre
principe de laïcité qui est un fondement
de notre république
alexandrine league et est ce que vous
avez le sentiment vous avez regardé
évidemment écouter tout ce qui s'est
passé
moi j'ai le sentiment là mais c'est
peut-être qu'on est encore un peu dans
l'émotion qui a une sorte de prise de
conscience il discours du président de
la république aux mureaux il ya cet
assassinat horrible on a quand même
l'impression que bayer une prise de
conscience qu'il ya un danger et qu'il
faut traiter ce danger est ce que vous
avez ce sentiment là aussi en regardant
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé cette
opinion mais je trouve que c'est pas
c'est pas nouveau c'est pas un sentiment
qui d'un coup à cause de ce qui s'est
passé les mots vendredi que que ça
commence comme ça ça fait longtemps
et petit à petit je trouve que il ya une
tension qui monte qui monte et que en
fait c'est pas nouveau ce sentiment
donc ça arrive de temps en temps ses
cinquante ans et ça ça continue à être
dans un contexte plus large des choses
c'est pas je trouve que c'est pas
individuel à ce qui s'est passé à les
autres attentats par exemple charlie
hebdo etc
c'est vrai que vous avez raison de
comparer ça peut-être
vincent où jean baptiste il ya eu cette
manifestation à la république comme j'ai
vu le medef les stations en 2015 après
les attentats de charlie hebdo
mais même si je pense moi qui ait une
prise de conscience on n'a pas non plus
retrouvé cette unanimité cette force qui
avait dans la manifestation du dimanche
qui avait suivi des attentes de ses
reliefs d'eau et de edu et du
supermarché cacher en 2015 vous avez ce
sentiment là ou pas moi je crois en un
mot que c'est tout à fait ça c'est
triste à dire mais il ya une sorte
d'habitude
finalement qui d'habitude il ya toujours
le même effroi évidemment à chaque fois
mais c'est quelque chose qui n'est plus
nouveau c'est quelque chose qui se
répètent et donc il y a évidemment ce
sentiment d'unité réunir autour de nos
valeurs communes de les dire
mais il a un quelque chose de déjà vu
donc je crois qu'il faut tout simplement
espérer que comme en virage donc que les
moyens de l'état puisse arriver à faire
face à cette situation et je crois que
c'est aussi important de rappeler à cet
égard qu' il y a les attentats qui
surviennent et qui s'ajoutent 20 par
rapport aux autres mais il ya aussi les
très nombreux attentats qui sont évités
par nos services
je crois que l'état on a eu des dizaines
centaines et qu' il faut aussi se
féliciter de cet activisme de l'état
pour essayer de faire échec à ce genre
de choses mais je crois que comme le
disait charles est alors le problème
bien que phénomène n'est pas locale en
national n'est globale et qu' il ya
aussi derrière des enjeux géopolitiques
stratégiques
oui mais également la présence française
au mali il y a cet activisme français
porter les valeurs de république à
l'étranger pour lutter contre les
groupuscules terroristes islamiques et
donc cela génère aussi une vendeuse de
haine de défiance qui peut se reproduire
sur sur le territoire alors dernière
question sur ce sujet je t'aime et
l'attentât qui avait des commissions
siège en leur siège de charlie hebdo
était le fait d'un paquet stade et qui
était réfugié celui de conflent et été
commis par un tchétchène qui étaient
enfants de réfugiés réfléchit lui même
évidemment on entend déjà des gens qui
disent il faut remettre en cause le
statut de réfugié certains disent il
faut tous les expulsés d'ailleurs il ya
évidemment plusieurs plusieurs
interventions sur ce sujet plusieurs
opinions pour c'est que ça pose un
problème de le statut de réfugié qu'il
faut le revoir qu'il faut contrôler
peut-être plus les réfugiés lyon
c'est un stage un statut de réfugié
politique et c'est notre responsabilité
aussi d'accueillir des personnes qui qui
qui sont poursuivis condamné dans dans
leur propre pays qui ne peuvent plus
vivre
attention à ne pas faire un amalgame
avec l'ensemble aussi il y a un statut
qui est réglementé qui est vérifiée
ensuite il n'ya pas que ces deux
réfugiés sur les problématiques
d'attentats et d'assassinats sauvage que
nous appelons le vent qu à voir ces
dernières années et il y a aussi des des
jeunes français directement donc aussi
disons partir dit il y en a ou s'il va
donc quitter attention attention à
l'amalgamé dans un moment d'émotion son
étang et puis comme on peut le voir ou
savoir que à chaque moment d'émotion
nous avons 1 1
une remontée de législation de volonté
de refaire une loi sur une loi comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure c'est
s'est malheureusement pas nouveau
rappelons-nous au moment de ce fameux
esprit du 11 janvier commandes soufflé
est retombé au fur et à mesure des
années derrière très vite
et rappelons-nous dernièrement puisque
il y a en ce moment le le jugement et
les éléments qui remonte l'histoire
aussi de 1,2 c est un tendre est charlie
rappelons-nous les débats qu'il ya eu
dès le début de
de ce jugement sur le fait que est-ce
qu'il faut remonter remontrer les
caricatures et cédera donc tout ça
revient régulièrement et à chaque fois
il y à cette interrogation 7 finalement
cette remise en cause de la liberté
d'expression et ça depuis depuis des
années donc attention à ces amalgames
attention à ces hésitations régulière
que nous retrouvons il faut être ferme
sur les fondements de notre république
et c'est la responsabilité de chaque
individu
mais la responsabilité de toutes les
institutions de tous les responsables
politiques
tout le monde doit aller dans ce sens de
nos fondements révolu qu'il intervienne
justement il ya les deux thèses fin
c'est un peu ce que tu viens d'y abattre
ont eu il ya ceux qui disent faites
attention parce que lorsque les
terroristes voudrait aussi c'est que
vous abandonniez vos valeurs justement
les valeurs démocratiques et les
principes démocratiques
et puis il ya on entend de l'autre côté
ce que je disais tout à l'heure ce qui
disait attention on va pas accueillir
des gens chez nous qui vont assassiner
des professeurs des journaux disent et
c'est là qu'ils vont commettre des actes
de terrorisme
quel est le partage entre c'est au fond
ces deux thèses c'est une question bien
vaste jeu le sentiment que il ya il ya
d'abord une première chose qui me font
rappelé être mais que le statut de
réfugié je pense que vincent aura
l'occasion de préciser aussi mais c'est
un statut international
ça fait quand même partie aussi on a
tous lu notre dame de paris je pense en
cinquième
ça fait aussi partie de notre patrimoine
historique à l'intérieur de notre dame
c'est quand même aussi l'un de nos
fleurons donc évidemment salman rushdie
a le statut de réfugié et donc on ne
peut pas jeter pour une expression un
peu française le bébé avec l'eau du bain
donc il faut faire vraiment très
attention à toucher à la législation et
je suis un peu d'accord avec ce qui a
été dit la logorrhée législatives n'a
jamais été une solution donc ça c'est
vraiment la première chose à dire
ensuite
quant à savoir si notre héroïne va
tenter directement à notre manière de
vivre et à notre esprit du 11 janvier
justement
oui je crois que c'est un petit peu le
but d idéologie radicale c'est de
considérer qu'aucune autre manière de
penser n'est la bonne mais je crois
aussi qu'on parle ici de franges
extrêmement minime de la population ou
mondiales que sont des radicaux et les
radicaux on a pu le voir malheureusement
dans l'histoire aussi avec les
phénomènes du troisième reich toute
radicalité est à bannir la seule raison
sur laquelle on pourrait travailler
c'est pourquoi en arrive-t-on jusqu'à la
radicalité politique religieuse qui
amène à ces actes de cruauté finalement
l'allemagne n'aurait même pas été dans
cette situation de crise économique deux
phénomènes vexatoires à la suite de la
première défaite de 1870 on aurait
peut-être a été jusque là donc je crois
que c'est sur les causes endogènes
il convient de travailler pour notamment
essayer de parvenir à un monde basé
parce que rappelons que c'est loin
d'être un phénomène uniquement nationale
donc je crois qu'il faut vraiment
arriver à comprendre cette idéologie
pour mieux lutter contre elle et pour
mieux évidemment défendre nos valeurs de
la république et les vivre au quotidien
vincent couronne je n'ai jamais rien ça
je voudrais oui oui allez-y les i
j'ajouterai juste un mois par rapport
aux réfugiés à temps pour dire que je
suis pas fier d'aller jusque là faut
pouvoir accueillir les ajustements mais
je voudrais qu'on revienne là-dessus pas
sur le même plan le plan sur le plan
juridique
jean charles ii disait tout à l'heure il
faudrait expulser des fichiers s est il
ya nadine morano est intervenu en disant
qu'il fallait expulser tous les ans
d'étrangers qui portent atteinte à notre
mode de vie et existe justement
d'expulser des fichiers s je propose
qu'on la voit et que vous nous expliquer
juridiquement comment ça se passe les
3000 étrangers fichier s pour
radicalisation il faut les expulser mais
pas dans quinze jours dans trois
semaines dans six mois
c'est maintenant qu'il faut le faire ça
fait des semaines et des mois pour leur
éclat vincent couronne oui bah c'est à
dire que nadine morano que que bfm tv a
sorti de sa torpeur hier comme à chaque
fois que l'on porte atteinte aux valeurs
chrétiennes de la france est bien là
déclaré sur sur cette chaîne en réaction
donc au meurtre ignoble cet enseignant
la siamu elle pâtit à conflans sainte
honorine qu'il fallait donc à arrêter
d'accueillir à en france tous ces
étrangers qui portent atteinte à notre
mode de vie est donc la solution qu'elle
préconise ces expulsés de france tous
ses fichiers pour radicalisation elle en
donne au chiffre de 3000
sauf que sur ses 3000 tous ne sont pas
des étrangers etc pour en tout cas ceux
qui sont français à nous en france
français de régler ce problème là et
expulser ceux qui sont étrangers
seulement parce qu'ils sont fichés s
alors là d'une part ça n'a pas de sens
et d'autre part c'est impossible en
droit de les expulser de manière
collective tous d'abord parce que pour
expulser il faut avoir commis certains
crimes ou délits particulièrement graves
des violences physiques du trafic de
stupéfiants le terrorisme etc
ou alors avoir un comportement général
qui menacent la sécurité des personnes
ou de l'état un fichier s ne peut donc
pas être expulsés du seul fait qu'ils
seraient fichés puisque justement la
fiche s a précisément pour objet de
surveiller les personnes indépendamment
de toute sanction pénale
vous trouvez ça injuste 1 le fait que
pour expulser il faille une enquête
pénale est une condamnation est bien ce
qui serait injuste ça serait de pouvoir
permettre d'expulser des gens sans de
condamnation de pouvoir permettre deux
condamnés sont jugés plus personne ne
serait à l'abri et ce serait le règne de
l'arbitraire c'est donc une belle erreur
là ici pour nadine morano
d'autant plus que l'homme qui a tué
l'enseignant n'aurait pas a priori mais
sa demande à être confirmée était fiché
s merci merci beaucoup pour cette toute
la situation dont jean-charles une
seconde justement parce que je voudrais
qu'on passe à l'autre fusée juste
peut-être votre radio parce que vous
vous allez dire voilà mais c'est l'état
du droit peut-être qu'on peut le changer
mais comme comment changer cette
situation parce que ça prend une
direction comme la vanille non je ne
suis pas du tout pour est tout à fait
d'accord avec tous et tout à fait
d'accord avec tout ce qui s'est dit la
tamoa que ce qu'a dit monsieur le maire
il faut surtout pas légiférer dans
l'urgence absolue ans quatre pires au
monde et je veux dire la loi n'est pas
faite pour assouvir les instants et les
réactions de la population
hollande manque quelque chose d'horrible
ça on est tous d'accord maintenant
nadine morano avec trois mille
expulsions c'est juste ridicule
je suis un peu étonné en revanche quand
vincent nous dit on peut pas expulser si
on peut expulser une personne parce que
les fichiers est c'est qu'on considère
que son comportement est dangereux mais
pas de façon arbitraire mais se dire ce
serait pas aberrant et c'est d'ailleurs
ce que se propose de faire le
gouvernement et c'est ce que emmanuel
macron annoncé aujourd'hui qu'il veut
mettre dehors 286 281 fichier s donc il
s'agit pas de faire une expulsion global
on va pas on va pas faire des bus à deux
étages et puis film et tout ça en
montrant les expulsions je sais bien que
c'est compliqué vis-à-vis des pays qui
doivent recevoir leurs ressortissants
qui n'acceptent bien évidemment pas
toujours et on les comprend n'ont pas
envie de récupérer selon on n'a plus
besoin ce dont on n'a plus envie
donc ça on est d'accord mais il est tout
à fait possible est concevable en tout
cas sans changer la loi de dire ça ne
correspond pas je pense que franchement
sur les fichiers s est bien sûr les
surveiller mais on n'est pas fiché est
ce par hasard non plus alors que l'on
fasse ça avec mesure on est d'accord
mais se dire là je soutiens gouvernement
qui dit on en a 2 180 ou pourrait mettre
dehors ne nous gênons pas si ça contrôle
site
encore une fois c'est il faut juste être
c'est assez basique et peut-être un peu
pris mais en dix ans doctorante et pour
accepter notre façon de vivre nos règles
nos usages et nos lois si on contrevient
et son arrivée fichier s je pense
qu'aucun de nous ni si ici des fichiers
est ce ça n'empêche pas on n'a pas les
mêmes idées on n'a pas les mêmes sont
donc voilà fichiers c'est quand même un
échelon dans le donjon
j'en parle je je je je ne dis pas on
peut tout à fait expulser des gens qui
sont fichés est ce ne sont pas les
expulser parce qu'ils sont fichés s on
les expulse là il ya une ancre une app
il ya eu une condamnation derrière donc
on n'explique pas qu'on excuse pas
quelqu'un juste par l'administration des
renseignements aux rails mines fischer s
à son égard pour ratification au sénat
parce que c'est c'est la porte ouverte à
toutes les dérives possibles de la part
de l'administration
comme je disais c'est la porte ouverte à
l'arbitraire il faut qu'on pouvoir
indépendant la justice puisse trancher
si oui ou non il y à un risque pour la
sécurité de l'état et dans ce cas-là
pouvoir expulser notre droit permet déjà
ce genre de choses
tout comme pour les réfugiés c'est à
l'appel et les traits de la loi à la loi
la courbe
vous l'avez très libératrice
mais pour les réfugiés on peut très bien
ne pas donner l'accès aux réfugiés un
l'asile aux réfugiés qui se considèrent
être une menace pour la sécurité des
biens ça c'est aussi possible
alors on pourra pas forcément les
expulser mais ils n'auront pas le statut
allez merci alors ce quoi voilà on a dit
ce qu'on pouvait sur cette affaire soit
d'accord qu'on dise quand même un mot de
la situation sanitaire et de cette
nouvelle guerre contre lacko vide jeudi
une nouvelle guerre parce que le
président de la république utiliser le
même le terme de couvre-feu il avait
déjà dit au mois de mars nous sommes en
guerre couvre feu c'est vrai que ce sont
des termes guerriers donc interdiction
de sortir après 21h comment
font les maires comme vous pour faire
appliquer cette mesure bertrand ou lyon
d'abord on regarde la télé comme tout le
monde on suit les informations au
maximum voire on suit aussi tous les
réseaux sociaux pour réussir à avoir
l'information
ensuite une fois qu'on a une information
on essaie de la vérifier
pour voir si c'est vraiment ça à
appliquer sur le terrain et ensuite on
passe l'information puisque c'est pas
nous qui en avons du coup la
responsabilité on transmet l'information
au mieux aux habitants et on essaie de
répondre après à toutes les
interrogations qui peuvent exister
dernier exemple en date avec ce
couvre-feu mais qui s'est assortie pour
le département des yvelines depuis
samedi d'un arrêté interdiction
interdisant l'accès aux équipements
sportifs couverts
or publics spécifiques donc je le
découvre sur sur twitter samedi et
aujourd'hui on essaye tant bien que mal
de dire à l'ensemble de nos associations
vous ne pouvez plus pratiqués pour les
personnes adultes dans l'ensemble de nos
gymnase voilà c'est un peu comme ça
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
voulait dire le maire préfet et
tant louée par le premier ministre ne
fonctionnait pas auparavant fonctionne
pas forcément plus aujourd'hui on peut
toujours demander aux élus locaux de
faire des plans de prévention et et de
participer à la mise en oeuvre des
directives ont fait en fonction des
informations en cours soit et du coup au
dernier moment et pendant ce temps là on
assiste à une sorte de course à
l'échalote avec avec cette épidémie dans
le cadre de laquelle on déconfite d'une
manière un peu particulière ou en tout
cas qui interroge un moment là c'est un
début d'euro confinement faut pas se
leurrer reconfirme ans aujourd'hui le
soir mais suivant les endroits c'est pas
forcément la même chose on limite pas
les déplacements
donc on va avoir les congés pendant
quinze jours qui démarrera aujourd'hui
et puis finalement on a une
un mixage à l'intérieur de l'ensemble du
territoire
comment ça va être dans quinze jours
finalement ou plutôt dans quatre
semaines
une fois qu'une fois que les gens sont
rentrés de vacances voilà c'est alors on
peut toujours dire que c'est à dire que
le gouvernement parce que c'est toujours
facile aussi les de taper sur l'exemple
ce qui concerne la vie on parle beaucoup
elle n'existe pas vraiment cette
concertation n'existe pas vraiment mais
aussi on a un certain nombre
d'interrogations sur finalement
l'apprentissage des premiers mois et
donc il y a quelques mois au mois de
février mars avril
est-ce que les leçons bien été tiré
voilà on s'interroge alors au niveau
local on met en application voilà je
mets qui met en application par exemple
discuter d'autres joueurs avec le maire
de placer vers le livre qui disait moi
je veux pas mettre même police
municipale et il a une police municipale
sous ses pas vous avez une âme à nyon on
a une police municipale à magny les
hameaux
est ce que c'est alors oui disait c'est
pas ma position est celle qui va
contrôler après 21h le fait qu'ils ont
surtout pas il faut me donner les moyens
de police d'état vous êtes sur la même
longueur d'onde là dessus bien sûr j'ai
alors on a la chance d'être en zone
gendarmerie sur la commune de vérité à
moi est une brigade directement
directement sur place
et pendant qu'on dans le confinement on
a travaillé main dans la main avec notre
brigade de gendarmerie
maintenant donc couvre-feu annoncé mis
en place vendredi soir samedi soir je me
suis aperçu qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de visites pour vérifier la bonne
mise en application du couvre feu dans
la commune de magny les hameaux gelé
découvert également sur les réseaux
sociaux
maintenant de 21h à 6h du matin c'est
les effectifs disons du et
régalien les a donc chargé le service de
la sécurité qui font appliqué ce
couvre-feu
vous avez noté nous d'aider des formes
d'incivilités ou pas vraiment les gens
plutôt respectée à votre d'après ce que
vous pouvez savoir 1 d'après d'après ce
dont je me suis aperçu depuis ma fenêtre
j'ai pas vu grand monde à partir de 21h
sur dans les rues de magny les hameaux
depuis ma fenêtre puisque je suis à
sortir je suis aussi sauf urgence un
supposé vidéo certainement
justement incertaine cette collaboration
coopération entre les services de l'état
et les les les élus locaux on les a
beaucoup mis en avant jean castex le
premier ministre notamment parle
beaucoup des territoires et des parle
beaucoup de sa fonction de maire
finalement l'impression que ça marche
pas si bien que ça moi je crois que ce
qui ruine souvent les bonnes volontés en
france c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
le colbertisme c'est à dire notre
tendance à avoir besoin de la signature
de l'indu contre tampon de l'autre et
serra avant d'en arriver à ce qu'une
initiative soit finalement porté à bien
donc il ya sûrement des choses à revoir
mais plutôt sur notre bureaucratie
kafkaïenne à mon avis je pense que ce
n'est pas un problème de
décentralisation j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire sur ce plateau mais c'est
vrai que je crois qu'on en est au
sixième acte de décentralisation avec à
chaque fois des mesures qu'ils se
reprennent et qui se contredisent donc
la liberté ont elle peut être là la
question et surtout celle des moyens on
est en train de discuter encore d'une
loi de finances qui retire de plus en
plus de financements aux collectivités
locales
et pourtant nous en demande de faire de
plus en plus donc il y a à mon avis un
paradoxe à vouloir
recentraliser discours pour justement
animé le sentiment national et on a
besoin finalement cette figure
présidentielle en france était une bonne
chose par exemple président prenne la
parole
essaye de jouer son rôle d'unité mais
après on ne peut pas demander à ce que
la décentralisation viennent pallier à
toutes les carences de l'état central
donc il ya à mon avis un vrai problème
de d'administration de mode
d'administration
on parle souvent des lois de
simplification qui finalement sont les
voix qui sert un peu à rien mais il
serait temps de simplifier le mode
d'action publique avec des
expérimentations locales avec la
possibilité aussi de donner plus de
moyens d'initiative et puis ça
fonctionnera à l'heure actuelle demandé
au maire d'agir en lieu et place de
l'état central qui en plus récupère la
capacité de contrôler avec en plus un
juge administratif qui est plus en plus
présent je crois que c'est complètement
antithétiques l'émission termine donc on
n'a pas trop le temps et c'est vrai que
y ait des coudes il ya des blocages on
les voit pourquoi l'allemagne a beaucoup
moins de 2 de cas et de morts que la
france peut-être parce que aussi la
coopération entre public et le privé a
beaucoup mieux fonctionné qu'il ne
fonctionne en france mais je voudrais
décennale
la haye la parole alexandrine viviez
vous avez 24 ans vous êtes étudiante
c'est dur à vivre le le couvre-feu comme
ça ben c'est un sentiment assez
particulier parce qu'on a l'impression
peut être ronde et non par nos parents
mais un peu par l'état donc c'est un peu
bizarre et même le sentiment de voir moi
j'habitais apparaît donc les jus les
rues complètement vide
ça fait un peu ce côté film d'horreur
mais moi personnellement je suis pour le
contre-feu le couvre feu
pardon et je trouve que justement les
les 15 à 25 ans et les personnes qui
transmettent le virus à ses le plus le
plus souvent est assez souvent parce que
du coup on a ce côté social interaction
et peut-être si frustrant pour nous mais
là pour le moment la responsabilité
individuelle est indispensable et donc
même si c'est un peu dur à vivre oui
parce que vous avez raison de dire c'est
vrai qu'on attend beaucoup de l'état
dans deux des mères etc
on parlait de la laïcité tout à l'heure
et des comportements individuels coupe
oeuvre en matière de santé aussi ainsi
aussi de responsabilités individuelles
fin de responsabilité de chacun non il
ya une responsabilité tout le monde
individuel est aussi collective et quand
elle est collective
c'est aussi une défense de nos moyens de
santé de nos moyens de recherche qui qui
est aussi indispensable
et là dessus on peut aussi voir
l'histoire de l'évolution de nos
services notre service public de santé
et de notre service public de recherche
aussi elle est elle aussi des problèmes
de gestion parce que le le budget le
budget de pas été assez considérable on
ne sait pas toujours c'est plutôt d'un
problème de gestion de ces budgets qui
qui qui pose problème
il ya une diminution des dividendes
manière générale et une diminution de
fermetures d'hôpitaux des fermetures
fait finalement des disparitions
proximité aussi du service de son une
manière générale quand on voit la
pénurie de médecins qu'on peut avoir
même dans les territoires comme le nôtre
c'est juste catastrophique et les
périodes de crise nous montre les
problématiques et finalement le bilan
d'une histoire de 40 ans de la france
est et c'est peut-être justement un
sursaut a essayé de voir et a commencé
en local en soit en trouvant les moyens
d'intervenir en local ce qui n'est pas
forcément facile quand on n'a plus de
budget dans les collectivités locales
mais du coup on doit pouvoir faire appel
à l'ensemble des citoyens pour pouvoir
finalement remonter notre
notre système institutionnel
démocratique et notre système de service
public mais pallier la pénurie de
médecins on paye un discours qu'on a
entendues même sous le gouvernement de
notre ami je sais pas qui était de dire
bastion si on baisse le nombre de
médecins
eh bien on bat sera aussi des dépenses
médicales
un dernier mot pour conclure alexandrine
on a parlé de terrorisme on a parlé de
lakovic vous avez 24 ans a trouvé que ce
monde et est désespérant ou pas
forcément c'est une question vous avez
redonné de l'espoir il faut la voir mais
aussi à comment on vit dans un monde
c'est compliqué mais que aussi dans les
années précédentes c'était compliqué
aussi on a trouvé un moyen il faut
continuer à chercher des solutions et
faire comme on peut face à la crise
sanitaire en tout cas je pense que comme
on a parlé de ça la responsabilité
individuelle c'est de vraiment oublié ce
côté égoïsme qu'on peut avoir et penser
aux autres et c'est que comme ça qu'on
peut on peut franchir à la prochaine
étape et part avec le terrorisme mais
pareil avec le plein de sujets durs
qu'on a trouvé des solutions
pensons aux autres est passé sur cette
parole combat qu'on va se quitter
merci beaucoup berthod audio c'est
pourquoi me charles veilleux maître du
clair merci beaucoup
jean charles lajoie denis merci beaucoup
jean baptiste du clerc et vincent
couronne et bat très vite pour un
nouveau pas fun le prochain poste sera
pas fameuse spéciale consacrée à
l'élection américaine
et puis après on parlera de faits divers
je vous raconterai tout ça ça va être
passionnant
merci beaucoup et à très vite pour un
nouveau prof
[Musique]